- Go down to the boardwalk.
The county fair's in town!
- With a nickel.
Get yourself some taffy.
(jazz music)
- Old ass candy.
- I'm thinkin' somethin' dusty.
- I'm expecting lots of
licorice which I don't like.
- I feel like their lives consisted
of taffy and butterscotch.
- It's just gonna be fruit.
You're just gonna hand us an apple.
- [Voiceover] Ah, the good
ole fashioned Charleston Chew!
- Cause the Charleston was probably
the new latest dance move.
- Oh, they smell good.
- This was a whole family's candy.
- That is a good visual, though
look at that.
- That's great.
- All right Charleston,
you got it goin' on.
This is good.
Like this is what you give to your kid
to make 'em shut up.
- It's like a Snickers
with no nuts or caramel.
- You can't eat this
in less than 24 hours.
- The Roaring 20s.
This tastes like sin.
- [Voiceover] Slo Poke!
- This guy looks high as Hell.
- Man, I did not wanna
be a dentist in the 20s.
- It makes me feel like
it's gonna slow me down
in life if I eat it.
- How are you supposed to eat this?
- This is it, guys.
- You could slap someone
'round the face with that.
- Oh my God!
- Actually, not that bad.
- It's like a Stretch Armstrong.
- There's that chew that
they're talkin' about.
- Dat chew!
- I think it's pretty clear that caramel
found its place once they
put it inside of candy bars.
Not made it its own thing.
- Can see why this one did
not stand the test of time.
- [Voiceover] Whoo! Sky Bar!
- Each little section is its own flavor.
- Four different types.
- Oh wait!
You got caramel, vanilla,
peanut and fudge.
- What depression?
I mean right?
- Cause I was hoping they'd
all be mixed together
and now I'm really disappointed
that each one is a different one.
- Aw, yeah.
You could share with your friends.
- It's not very good chocolate.
- Caramel's pretty crappy.
- The fudge is pretty good.
- Well, they all taste the same.
So that fun is gone.
- Ew! It's all over your face.
- This does not look like vanilla.
- They're all the same consistency!
- I would say the Sky Bar
is my favorite so far.
It's got the most going on for it.
- Candy coated peanuts.
- Blech.
- This looks like ibuprofen.
- But, it just doesn't look
like it should be candy.
Baked beans is with barbecue.
- They're like... Oh my God!
- Oh! Was I not supposed to bite into it?
- (gags) That was my tooth!
- I like them.
- Mmm. This is so good!
- Too high sugar to peanut ratio.
- This is like M&Ms without the chocolate.
- I think they're weird.
- They are weird, but
they're kind of good weird.
- [Voiceover] Big Hunk!
- Oh yeah, this is my kinda candy.
The Big Hunk.
- Cure for the snack attack.
- Place bar firmly in one hand
then smack your Big
Hunk on a hard surface.
- One, two, three.
(smacking)
(shouting)
- You know the house wives are kinda like
sexually repressed and
they just need to be like
(smack)
Yes!
- Tastes like Lucky Charms.
- Oh this flavor!
This toffee.
- It's pretty good, though.
This is the best one.
- Candy has come a long way.
- Yeah, I was expecting
it to taste terrible
and have no flavor, but it
was actually pretty good.
- I think in the olden days,
candy you worked for it,
you got the reward when you earned it.
- Can we have like some Sour Punch Straws
and Reese's now?
- [Voiceover] Ready to go
to the box social, Gerdy?
- I gotta pull on my taffy.
- These petunias are for you.
- Also got milk.